okay so you're here in New York and I'm
thinking because you've got lovely cap
and a sweater on that it's all about the
Presidents Cup so let us know exactly
what's going on what is the Presidents
Cup Series because some of our listeners
are just sports fans but there may be
just discovering golf so what is the
president of what well I guess if you've
been on this planet for a while I guess
you probably have heard of something
called the Ryder Cup which is yes
basically the European Tour versus the
US tour in golf yeah I'm kind of a
bragging rights kind of thing it's been
going on for a really long time and
that's become a really really big event
but that's owned by the PGA of America
at the PGA Tour which is really kind of
the powerful organization which kind of
runs the tour on a regular basis kind of
wanted to get in on the mix so they
created their own thing called the
Presidents Cup which is the US team
versus everyone else in the world except
for Europe which is quite a lot of good
golfers you know generally there's four
or five of the top ten in the world of
this out of that sort of area of the
world so to created this event I think
in the early 90s this is about nine or
ten now it's every two years every other
Ryder Cup year so it's um this year at
Liberty National which is staring at the
Statue of Liberty and the skyline in New
York and happens to be the very best
golf club in the world outside of any
other Golf Club I own so sorry yes
staying good man this guy knows what
he's doing we're staying down um kind of
Wall Street way only Battery Park we get
the ferry everyday and beautiful if
anyone ever wants to see professional
golfers actually get truly passionate go
to a Presidents Cup a Ryder Cup because
it means a lot more when you're playing
for who's gonna win one word answer
internationals yeah there you go will be
President does it refer to all of the
Presidents the minis of every president
that's ever been 45 of them 4500 of the
oates American Presidents Cup yeah oh
okay I'm sorry
goodness didn't have one so they've now
they've got one okay okay Fogle we
measure absolute pleasure is very better
I hope we can get you back when you're
really cool to talk to I just quit I
think that the putting green that's
actually real grass real grass because
I've never seen grass that looks like
putting green grass oh yeah sure you
guys must like genetically engineer that
stuff believe it or not we do I think
maybe we should come back and talk about
absolutely on a greenskeeper in well
that's all playing with science show if
you really love what we do
Chuck tell them where to go I'll go
ahead and subscribe wherever you get
your podcast so coverage of the
Presidents Cup will be on the Golf
Channel on Thursday and Friday and NBC
on Saturday and Sunday thanks for
watching playing with science